descenso de la población por primera vez
en más de 60 años el año pasado hubo en
China casi un millón de nacimientos
menos que el año anterior
de hecho la tasa de natalidad de china
en 2022 fue menos de la mitad que hace
10 años con solo 6,77 nacimientos por
cada mil habitantes
una cifra 10 puntos menos que la tasa de
natalidad de India y cinco puntos por
debajo de Francia pero aún más
significativo la cantidad de muertes en
el país superó a la de nacimiento el
primer caso de este tipo desde 1961
durante el gobierno de Mao sedong gran
parte del descenso demográfico es
consecuencia de la política del hijo
único impuesta entre 1980 y 2015 pero
existen otras razones para el descenso
china es uno de los países más caros del
mundo para criar a un niño
no tengo pensado tener hijos y aunque
algún día me casé me gustaría tener una
relación sin hijos
una combinación de factores que ha dado
lugar a una población cada vez más
envejecida y ha dado paso a la
preocupación de que un día china no
tenga suficientes personas en edad de
trabajar para seguir siendo una
superpotencia mundial el fenómeno se
vería reflejado en una escasez de mano
de obra que también reduciría los
ingresos Fiscales y las cotizaciones a
un sistema de pensiones Ya bajo presión
es preocupante porque los jóvenes ya no
quieren tener hijos porque el país
envejece Y eso crea presión en nuestra
sociedad
los gobiernos locales han puesto en
marcha varias medidas para animar a la
gente a tener más hijos entre ellas
deducciones Fiscales permisos de
maternidad más largos y ayudas a la
vivienda pero nos espera que estas
medidas sean suficientes para frenar la
tendencia a largo plazo en 2035 un
tercio de la población tendrá más de 60
años